l'avis de camionneurs c'est loin d'être
facile
les journées sont longues les trajets
peuvent durer des semaines
et bien s'alimenter c'est tout un défi
le monde pense qu'on mangeuse la
cochonnerie manour italien et
camionneuse depuis quatre ans on mange
chanter à notre demande
manon lance un appel aux 28 mille
membres du groupe camionneurs
camionneuse du québec 2.1
je m'attache caire qui montre des
débours santé quand ma mère mais c'est
sûr qu'on mange
son appel porte fruit les photos
partagées montrent une tendance
on compte beaucoup moins deux repas au
resto qu'on ne l'aurait imaginé
un coach aurait poussé ma demande et je
penserai pas 200 pièces par semaine à
manger les restaurants
on est sur eux les routiers astag voir
ça mange pas camiade à une camionneuse
qu'est ce que vous mangez l'on puisse le
sanwi tch à quoi gerbant
avec ta matin
quand les gens
c'est gênant salalah les pathologies du
ballon au nez des patates et vous qui
l'avez fait
bonsoir c'est mamie mais là encore d'un
gros des bois est ce que ça vous arrive
de manger la nourriture
ça coûte trop cher qui tue c'est pas mal
ça pour l'amiante notamment être un peu
plus facile comme ça vient
c'est devant la 14e patrouille les
lanières de drogue
c'était quand même un tube est quand
même possible mais j'étais unis se
soient mis knock al d'antenne 2 aux
normes énoncées plus à nos tarifs
mais tout s'est produit à faire là donc
c'est tout une jambe foule est on fera
les paras tôt un camion oui on va le
fuient en masse rigaux andré le monde se
démarque par la qualité de son
alimentation
le chauffeur de 53 ans a préparé tous
ses repas pour la semaine les scieries
dieu qui est chaumont avec des fruits du
riz ma bouffe d'un camion c'est moi qui
a préparé maison dimanche
je fais toutes mes plongeons amputé
diplo d'amour rigide âgé des petits
objets des légumes se sont gonflés
mignot le mont montjuic langer qui je le
vois le plus bel exemple c'est lui
michel parent salon cette camionneurs le
plus grand bien
au total un peu plus de 20 c'est un
endroit qui demande beaucoup qui
demandent de l'attention faux est
éveillé et ses deux longues heures de
conduite c'est un entre 11 et 13 heures
de conduite par jour sans oublier le
chargement et le déchargement je n'ai
pensé à vous
sur la bo a nourri te jettent ou alors
on arrive à l'alto routière
et j'avais quand même une tendance plus
à arrêter dans les grosses chaînes mais
j'ai réalisé que souvent c'est moi qui
paient la note
en bout de ligne côté santé lorsqu'après
quelques dates
tu vois tes cheveux qui sont enflés à
c'était quand même assis tout le temps
contrairement au mouvement
je me nourris mieux je fais un peu plus
d'exercices marché m'arrêter tout cela
combiné enfants qui font que ça rend mon
métier mon travail de tous les jours
plus agréable et plus facile ledit matin
à sainte anne des lacs michel cuisine
sert pas pour la semaine avec sa
conjointe qui nord trop-plein jacky
barbecue haricots saint pons contre nous
et selon mon repos ne revient peut-être
un but d'allart économiquement son
budget et santé je suis gardien à tous
les nouveaux fruits et légumes noix
protéines végétales
michel c'est le nouveau guide
alimentaire canadien sur deux pattes ou
sur dire où je me nourris à 80%
végétarien donc dans ma semaine je vais
avoir un rapport sinon 2 où il ya une
portion de viande ou dépenses je dois
avouer que j'étais un peu réticent parce
que un bon steak tu j'aime ça j'ai vu
mes journées être plus facile en bout de
ligne affaires à maurice un végétarien
bon ben merci ben semaine le dîner ça va
être mon repos le plus consistant
un peu plus tôt dans l'après midi je
vais prendre une pause et là je vais me
préparer une assiette soit de noix avec
un quartier de pomme orange et ou des
crudités avec une trempette et annuler
ces jeunes chocolat malgré quelques
écarts de conduite
les camionneurs demeurent préoccupés par
leur état de santé
enfin pour la grande activité congo
c'est joe dassin des mois j'ai pas dû
monter en cause d'un synthé deux ans
passés l'état camilla dalby tour face à
carrasso quand vous avez une fringale
qu'est ce que vous mangez sur la rue bat
le jeu des pistaches pour l'instant non
richie s'est pas vraiment 400 t il
et puis quand même 60 riva douzaine dans
les dépanneurs des haltes routières plus
facile de trouver chip ses chocolats que
fruits et légumes
il est dit au vu des bananes sur dives
au début des primes ce matin à pau au
québec on n'est pas vraiment choyés en
fait halte routière là moi je pense
qu'il pourrait y avoir des kiosques
salade avec poulet
et encore là de certaines grandes
chaînes l'ofs
mais c'est une petite portion
je suis sûr que à court et moyen terme
il ya un succès avant de prendre sa
retraite michel donne de la formation ou
jeune camionneur
il en profite pour leur parler
d'alimentation j'ai formé quelques
chauffeurs et qui a eu un hiver avec la
mentalité du chauffeur d'un camion qui
manque du fast-food tout le temps et
lorsqu'il voyait les reports j'avais
souvent avant même la formation d'un
mois qu'ils étaient avec moi déjà dans
la dernière semaine qui arrive avec un
pro cuisine et de la maison dans un pot
de vin dont je me disais on a franchi
une étape
donc si la personne part de jeu pour moi
0 report maison à ne serait-ce qu 4 po
maison ils vont y prendre goût mais
aussi est tranquillement changer ça
samson alimentaire
[Musique]